welcome to Easy Bake battle I'm Anthony
perovski and I'm here to show you that
good food doesn't have to be complicated
or fancy smells pretty tasty in there
yum my guess is Gordon Ramsay
Gordon Ramsay I like apologize for
taking up air in a room when I come in
and Gordon Ramsay comes in he's got a
very different very different approach
and I love him I would like to say and
I'm not comparing myself to her Talent
at all Ina Garten comes off as like
gentle okay and unintimidating
and I would say that I feel like I try
to do that
[Music]
this is gonna be good okay who
the best 10. I'm sorry that was too
quick I should have pretended to think
about that for a second did you have an
Easy Bake Oven as a kid did not
um I really wanted one I saw the
commercials on TV when I was watching
Saturday morning cartoons with my
sisters and so I kind of get to relive
my childhood dream of not having one by
literally having a show that honors it
is it so hard for you to watch someone
make a mistake and you just want to help
them
okay so the mistakes not as much but I
do have my pet peeves I'm just gonna get
right into it on easy bake one of the
appliances that people can use in one of
the challenges was a deep fryer I love
fried food but as soon as anything comes
out of the fryer if it's Savory you have
to Salt it immediately because then
you're just going to be biting into
crunch with no flavor whatsoever so I
have like little things that kind of
like make my temple twitch on the end
where I'm just like salt it while it's
hot so the salt clings to it so it hits
your lips when you take a bite but I
can't say that but sometimes I do
because I can't help myself